hey it's Joey and welcome to better
ideas so if you're anything like me
you'll find it sometimes really
difficult to just dive into work and I'm
talking not really about procrastination
but the specific inability to eliminate
distractions get into a flow state of
just super concentrated uninterrupted
deep good work this is especially a
problem in today's day and age you got
ten emails you got to answer the
Facebook page is open somebody just like
your post on Instagram and you forgot
you didn't respond to a facebook message
on a group chat about a group project
something like that there's a million
things you have to worry about sometimes
even if you do manage to begin a project
it's not really focused work you might
have Facebook still open there might be
people talking in the background moral
of the story is we need to be able to
just block out all distractions the
outside world for a little while and
just focus in hone in on one thing for a
long period of time this is something
called deep work and it's a skill that
is becoming increasingly rare in today's
social media addictive society but
increasingly important deep work is
professional activities performed in a
state of distraction free concentration
that push your cognitive capabilities to
their limit shallow work is non
cognitively demanding logistical style
tasks often perform while distracted
these efforts tend not to create much
new value in the world and are easy to
replicate so what Cal Newport is getting
at in his book is that today we're
treating everything like shallow work
even things that really need our full
undivided attention which is unfortunate
because to produce at your peak level
you have to be able to give something
you're a hundred percent undivided
attention
in other words deep work channels every
little fiber of productivity you have
and optimizes your performance the nice
thing about deep work is that it allows
you to be fully present and immersed in
whatever you're doing at the time even
when you're not working since after a
deep work session when you're done
you're done you can then leave your
difficult work for the day and forget
about it and then you can focus in on
having a really relaxing fulfilling
recharging break you could even start
doing the shallow work that means doing
like responding to your emails writing
that thank-you card you need to do all
without having that big looming cloud of
guilt in the back of your
mind that big important task because you
haven't done yet you've already expended
all your brainpower so now you have just
the amount of brainpower you need to
respond to those emails do the less
important stuff like writing a thank-you
card
responding your group messaged email
thing whatever I said earlier in the
video you can do that now because you
don't really need a whole lot of
brainpower do that anyways but if
there's one takeaway from this video
would be the importance of giving
something your full and undivided
attention it optimizes your performance
and it's so difficult to do that these
days with the internet so give it a try
so it's been a while that's mostly
because I was kicked out of my routine
when I was making videos before I was
just going to class I would come back
write a script for the video and then
maybe shoot it the next day after class
you know it was a nice little system add
going on but then exam season hit and it
was a hellish exam season blabbity
blabbity blah to move out of my
apartment now I'm back in my hometown
crazy crazy crazy but now I'm making a
new routine and I'm going to release a
better ideas video every Tuesday and
Thursday every single week for the whole
summer
discipline